bien mesdames Messieurs mes chers
collègues la commission d'enquête
chargée d'établir les raisons de la
perte de souveraineté d'indépendance
énergétique de la France poursuit donc
ces travaux et à l'honneur d'accueillir
monsieur Jean-Louis Borloo merci de
votre présence monsieur le ministre le
président Raphaël chez l'homme berger
m'a retenu m'a demandé en qualité de
vice-président de la commission de le
remplacer pour organiser les débats
monsieur le ministre vous avez exercé
des fonctions ministérielles importantes
dont celle d'un Ministre en charge un
large secteur comprenant notamment
l'écologie et l'énergie dans ce domaine
votre mandat a été marqué par une
initiative originale l'organisation du
Grenelle de l'environnement 2007 visant
à jeter les bases d'une gouvernance
environnementale et aboutissant à deux
lois celle du 3 août 2009 de
programmation dites Grenelle 1 et celle
du 12 juillet 2010 dite Grenelle 2 ainsi
qu'à l'élaboration d'une programmation
des investissements pour l'électricité
la chaleur et le gaz
avec pour objectif de parvenir à
l'horizon 2050 à diviser par 4 les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
l'ambition de ce projet s'est traduite
par des engagements dans 6 secteurs dans
celui de l'énergie mais aussi dans les
secteurs du bâtiment des transports de
la santé de l'agriculture et de la
biodiversité avec notamment la trame
verte elle s'est traduite aussi par
différents instruments de programmation
comme le plan de rénovation énergétique
de l'habitat et une programmation des
investissements de production et
d'approvisionnement en énergie de la
France à l'horizon 2020 qui devait
comporter trois volets électricité gaz
et chaleur la programmation plus réelle
des investissements de production
d'électricité
2009-2020 a ainsi décliné les objectifs
que vous aviez fixé des 2008 je cite
notre responsabilité est de préparer et
d'accompagner la France dans cette
transition énergétique pour cela la
France doit engager un vaste programme
d'équipements en énergie décarbonée en
particulier nous devons intensifier
massivement le développement
les énergies renouvelables et établir le
calendrier de mise en place du programme
de centrale nucléaire de 3e génération
lancée par le Président de la République
dans le domaine qui intéresse la
commission d'enquête on peut relever 4
orientations législatives la baisse des
consommations d'énergie la réduction du
recours aux ressources fossiles la
multiplication par 2 à l'horizon 2020
des énergies renouvelables avec
notamment un plan de relance de
l'hydroélectricité et le soutien à la
recherche après ces quelques éléments
concernant les politiques publiques que
vous avez définies et mise en oeuvre il
ne revient monsieur le ministre en
application de l'article 6 de
l'ordonnance du 17 novembre 1958 de vous
demander de prêter serment de dire la
vérité toute la vérité rien que la
vérité je vous invite en conséquence
monsieur ministre a levé la main droite
et à dire je le jure
je vous remercie et avant de donner la
parole on va déroger aux règles avant de
donner la parole aux rapporteur non
après vous avoir donné la parole pardon
monsieur le ministre pour un exposé une
quinzaine de minutes ne dérangeront un
peu la règle voilà et je céderai la
parole à notre collègue Julie larnos qui
a des impératifs de transport et qui
aura donc l'occasion de vous poser la
première question de cette noble
assemblée monsieur le mini je vous
laisse la parole
c'est le Président Madame Monsieur s'il
y a un impératif peut même inverser si
ça vous arrange bon d'abord merci de
cette de cette invitation
les choses assez simplement
dans cette période
2007 2010 que je connais mieux
les situations de la France était
et le suivant à part électronucléaire
hérité des décisions 1969 un parc
robuste
duplicable industriellement
permettant d'avoir une énergie nucléaire
peu chère
et on notre production tourne à 410
térats à peu près
soutenance là par de l'hydroélectricité
sérieuse et puissante aux alentours de
60 ou 70 terawatts le solde 50 à 60
étant de gaz et et la fin du charbon un
peu de biomasse enfin c'était pas très
significatif
la réputation de DFC absolument mondiale
ce qui permet d'ailleurs d'avoir des
contrats d'exportation comme l'Afrique
du Sud et la Chine à l'époque
pour autant le dispositif français avait
prévu la construction de deux centrales
les deux premières opérés en France
celle de Flamanville qui a été proposé
par edfd 2004 qui a fait l'objet d'un
cadre en 2005 et dans les travaux ont
démarré en plein Grenelle de
l'environnement
pour une mise en service vers 2012 et
pour un prix connu annoncé à l'époque de
3 milliards et demi un peu moins de 4
milliards d'euros
pour autant pendant le Grenelle je le
dis parce que je j'ai écouté avec
beaucoup d'intérêts interventions de
Jean-Marc joncourci qui parlait de durée
longue et de consensus du pays je crois
que c'est extrêmement important
je voudrais simplement dire que le
Grenelle de l'environnement réunissait
cinq collèges
dont le collège des ONG et il y avait un
partenaire puissant qui était Greenpeace
autant l'affaire de la montagne d'or en
Guyane extraction minière
était son annulation était une condition
de la participation au Grenelle de la
part des ONG
par le nucléaire
je ne dis pas qu'il soutenait le parc
nucléaire mais accepter que s'il y avait
voilà un débat franc de compensation et
a-t-elle enseigne que le décret
d'autorisation de Pandi a été signée
pendant le Grenelle
je le dis parce que
voilà ce sont des sujets assez longs et
il y avait pas de caricature de position
voilà ce que je voulais dire puisque
j'entends beaucoup de choses
la responsabilité écologique etc en
l'occurrence quand on se met à
travailler au fond alors il y avait des
contreparties et qui était stimulante la
première c'était que
on lance un énorme plan d'énergie
renouvelable pour avoir le détail qui
était à l'épo puissante les moyens de la
même ont été renforcés considérablement
un peu plus d'un milliard d'euros
supplémentaires le Plan Bâtiment parce
qu'en gros il y a un bâtiment bâtiment
et transport les deux grands sujets
le Plan Bâtiment on était très en retard
on nous comparer aux Allemands et aux
Suisses à l'époque le plan bâtiment neuf
les nouvelles constructions ont fait
l'objet de normes BBC les écoquartiers
la RT 2012 devenue 2020 enfin bon il y
avait un Plan Bâtiment puissant il y
avait le programme de rénovation
thermique notamment pilotée par le monde
HLM qui a été
assez puissant les diagnostics
énergétiques les les prêts à taux zéro
pour les particuliers les éco-prés à
taux zéro les artisans il y avait le
label éco-ortisan il y avait un travail
de formation fait d'ailleurs par les
organisations professionnelles donc il y
avait un mouvement général
à mon avis
avec deux difficultés les contrats de
performance énergétiques ont mis son
complexe sont indispensables parce
qu'ils permettent de garantir et d'avoir
un traitement global et d'utiliser
l'économie pour financer
l'investissement mais à l'époque nous
n'avions pas cette là on l'a pas vu on
l'a pas on n'avait pas fait pour les
bâtiments publics je crois que c'est en
train d'être médié à l'Assemblée
nationale d'ailleurs actuellement parce
qu'elles sont on parle d'un milliard de
mètres carrés quand même bon
et sur les transports il y a eu un plan
assez puissant souvenez-vous le plan si
propre le Grenelle avait prévu de
financer je ne sais plus si c'est 20 ou
30% des investissements des
collectivités à l'idée c'était que on
est à
on soit moins de 7 minutes d'un arrêt de
site propre tramway ou à haute à haute
efficacité je sais plus comment
s'appeler s'appeler les autres
le lancement du canal senor je rappelle
que l'objectif c'est 500 000 camions sur
le canal plutôt que sur les autoroutes
le bonus malus écologique sur les
voitures qui a eu un effet considérable
sur les grammes de CO2 des voitures
neuves
le financement le lancement de trois
lignes TGV qui est au-delà de leur
qualité particulière mais surtout vos
questions à libérer des sillons pour le
fret on avait et on a toujours une vraie
difficulté sur le fret ferroviaire
le travail de reconfiguration de la
gouvernance des ports qui devait avoir
pour conséquence qui a interlombe
ferroviaire parce que 88% je crois du
tonnage de nos ports sur par camions et
et pas de manière ferroviaire qu'est-ce
qu'on avait encore
les autoroutes maritimes les autoroutes
ferroviaires consiste à mettre un camion
sur le train la première ligne avait été
inaugurée c'était Perpignan Luxembourg
ou à côté de Luxembourg bref un
dispositif relativement puissant pour
voilà qui accompagnait ce mouvement là
j'ajoute que pour autant nous avions
prévu une inscription sur les recherches
sur les Hydroïdes sur les hydroliennes
et sur les SMR parce que c'était le
début des voilà c'était un sujet qui
commençait à monter de mémoire je crois
que c'était 600 millions dans le grand
emprunt pour les SMS et il y avait
également le projet Astrid pour 500 ou
600 millions qu'on soutenait de la même
manière comme le site d'enrichissement
d'uranium de baisse de donc
on avait un dispositif français qui
était robuste et bien pour les
consommateurs et la compétitivité
française le plus décarboné ou à peu
près des pays industriels
[Musique]
et des capacités à venir à la fois par
deux EPR par Astrid pas Georges Besse 2
par les renouvelables et
les SMS ou une réflexion sur
l'avenir n'est pas forcément que le pH
enfin
nucléaire ne veut pas dire que toi mon
c'est l'UPR le père ou rien ça m'était
pas cause le père parce qu'à l'époque il
y avait pas de raison de le mettre en
cause il y avait des petits inquiétudes
sur sa taille et de l'acceptabilité et
avec un des inquiétudes sur le prix car
l'affaire des Émirats arabes unis à
l'époque est à la fois un problème de
gouvernance de la filière mais c'est
aussi parce que en vrai le réacteur
coréen et au kilowatt-heure produit de
fournit chef puisque nous proposions
pour le père donc il y a des inquiétudes
mais il n'y a pas de remise en cause du
tout on n'avait pas imaginé qu'il y ait
ce que vous savez ce que vous connaissez
depuis en termes de délai et en termes
de coûts alors il y avait quand même des
des difficultés et des points de
vigilance il y en avait en matière
d'indépendance
et de votre commission de me semble-t-il
il y avait l'alerte déjà à l'époque du
gaz en provenance de Russie qui je vous
le rappelle transité par l'Ukraine il y
a eu des contentieux commerciaux peu
importe mais enfin en gros en janvier
2009 c'est ma mémoire est bonne
quasi arrêt de la de la pointe de la de
l'utilisation de de ce gazoduc
ça a été une tension courte mais c'était
la quatrième en cinq ans d'où le soutien
à ce qui est un troisième port métallier
français à Dunkerque
deuxième sujet de dépendance ou
d'indépendance que l'on anticipait sans
y voir très clair c'est le sujet des
métaux stratégiques ou des métaux rares
et nous avions donc à l'époque installé
le comité le comité pour les métaux
stratégiques qui regroupaient le
ministère le BRGM les grands industriels
les grands opérateurs pour essayer d'y
voir pas de faire une cartographie
cartographie et une évaluation des
besoins internes
et puis on avait un troisième une
troisième préoccupation
physiquement le dispositif est bon mais
on avait quelques soucis quand même
premier souci
une pression des des fournisseurs
alternatifs AEDF
il y en avait et il y en a des grandes
sur le gros on va dire le monopole def
pour pour dire les choses simplifiées on
avait une deuxième difficulté qui était
que nous avions des prix régulés dont
qui n'avait été accepté que par mesure
transitoire et provisoire et qui venait
échéance en juillet 2010 si ma mémoire
est bonne
se rajouter à ça le fait qu'il y avait
besoin de production de capacités
supplémentaires notamment pour les
pointes et il était normal de mettre à
contribution les nouveaux entrants pour
ça il fallait qu'on ait un dispositif
qui est lisier incite et puis je rajoute
à ça que la France était engagée depuis
15 ans ou 20 ans avait soutenu la
libération du marché de l'énergie marché
européen de l'énergie et nous avions
dans cette logique là une pression
énorme qui s'était traduite par deux
instructions
une procédure d'infraction au titre de
la de la directive de 2003
et plus grave si j'ose dire et et cette
procédure était soutenue je vous
rappelle par le Conseil constitution
constitutionnel qui est dans un arrêt de
2006 avait indiqué que nous n'étions pas
conforme au droit européen mais plus
embêtant parce que ça je me souviens
très très bien de ce moment de cette
arbitrage parce que c'était une vraie
bataille
l'infraction pourrait être d'État alors
on était quasi au bout du processus et
je rappelle que la qualification pour
être d'État c'est d'écart c'est c'est
l'aide anormal vu par la règle ce n'est
pas tricé la règle et le remboursement
par le bénéficiaire
pour toute la durée de l'aide
on avait que des provisoires et pas
clair parce que en fonction de la
situation il y avait pas les mêmes
tarifs il y avait pas de visibilité à
terme et donc pas de capacité
d'investissement sur les capacités de
production notamment pour les pointes
donc situation baroque et donc on est on
se retrouve dans un moment où il faut
essayer de conjuguer des intérêts qui
sont pas tout à fait alignés
la volonté de continuer à protéger le
consommateur français bénéficiant on
appelait ça la rente nucléaire à
l'époque et en même temps permettre à
des nouveaux entrants et à des
investissements marginal complémentaires
de capacité et ben joindre les deux et
éteindre par ailleurs les contentieux
avec Direct Énergie qui venaient gagner
contre EDF et la commission qui était
devant la porte c'est à nous réveiller
l'infraction pour trois mois après bon
donc c'était un peu complet la
commission chancea
qui était composée de parlementaire de
tout bord d'ailleurs et de et
d'ingénieurs et de et d'experts et
techniciens qui a auditionné tout ce que
la France compte d'énergie
ou d'utilisateurs de l'énergie
à écarter deux pistes le démantèlement
d'EDF parce que c'était sur la table de
à écarter la taxation sur le parc
historique au profit des alternatives
pour proposer un système suivant
l'accès régulé à l'énergie nucléaire à
hauteur de 20% si ma mémor est bonne de
la production au nom à son terrawatt
exactement ce n'était pas en pourcentage
à son terrain watts qui à l'époque
représentait une vingtaine de pour cent
je crois
à condition alors un tarif donc un accès
régulier en échange de quoi
ça nous permettait de maintenir
l'avantage pour le consommateur sur les
prix
ce tarif devait être piloté en
permanence et en tout cas annuellement
avec rideaux intégré trois notions le
financement du parc historique
le démantèlement là maintenant c'est les
améliorations de sécurité le grand
carénage
et en contrepartie il devait être fait
vérifier annuellement que les
alternatives les nouveaux entrants
investissent dans des capacités de
production
le prix commission de chanceux avait
fixe proposé avec suggéré après tout
d'un prix à 32 34 me semble-t-il la
creux à 36 38 quelque chose comme ça et
finalement la fixer après le débat
parlementaire c'est vraiment débat
parlementaire à 40 devenus très vite
Fukushima 42 euros mais en réalité alors
c'est c'est un objet hybride
c'est pas bien ça c'est la seule
certitude c'est pas possible de garder
un outil comme celui-là s'il y a pas un
pilotage quasi permanent avec la creux
avec tous les avis etc voilà c'était les
difficultés que nous avions à l'époque
où finalement la commission voilà tous
il y a plus de contentieux les contrôler
que les alternatives se sont arrêtés la
situation
ait été celle là
j'ajoute que à l'époque la SN était une
était une une instance qui a beaucoup
guidé les autres autorités de sûreté
européennes parce qu'elle était
considérée comme un modèle
la séparation RTE enedis d'aide se fait
dans de bonnes conditions
fonctionnellement alors que tout
certains pouvaient dire que bon ça
stresse c'était c'était une chimère non
c'est pas vrai c'était bien fait
voilà quelle était la situation de
l'époque après il y a eu ce que vous
savez il y a eu Fukushima et il y a eu
un certain nombre de et moi je les juge
pas je suis pas là pour ça je n'ai pas
dangereux personnel mais bon il y a la
réponse
il y a
la raie d'Astrid il y a une loi qui
réduit un peu le parc nucléaire quoi
enfin symboliquement 75 50 qu'est-ce qui
a eu d'autres il y a eu
il y a pas j'ai pas vu grand chose sur
les soutiens au SMR à l'époque et
voilà
il y a eu un retournement d'opinion je
veux dire il est clair que cette filière
n'a pas été à ce moment-là choyé
c'est juste factuel et moi je me
souviens du traumatisme de Fukushima
c'était pas en charge mais c'est pour ça
que je ne porte pas de jugement de
valeur là-dessus enfin c'est à fait et
puis dernier fait aussi un point pardon
on avait fini pour présentation rapide
il y avait ce sujet de
d'entretien et de grands carénage
déjà à l'époque le président de F Henri
Proglio ne cesser de dire
la stratégie
d'allongement elle est inévitable
on bénéficie d'un parquet de encore
jeune mais qui va être de moins en moins
jeune les quatre travaux de grosses
réparation d'anticipation doivent être
beaucoup plus importants et il faut
faire le grand carénage qu'il évalue à
l'époque à 30 milliards j'ai lu qu'il
était pour l'instant plutôt aux
alentours de 50 ou 60 milliards mais
pour vous dire vrai je n'arrive pas à
comprendre exactement où on en est de ce
grand carénage pour permettre
l'évolution à terme sous réserve des
accords de l'ASN de la situation donc
voilà sur le passé
sentiment sur les situations actuelles
mais peut-être plus en répondant à votre
question de façon à libérer le micro
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre une
fois n'est pas coutume donc je vais
laisser la parole à Julie d'ailleurs ce
qui doit nous quitter assez rapidement
et ensuite je passerai la parole
rapporteur
merci monsieur le président le
rapporteur pouvait passer avant moi je
montrais dans plus d'une heure donc ça
mais je vous remercie pour
cet entorse au bon règlement j'ai trois
volets de questions le premier
concerne le paquet énergie climat et la
propretation énergétique 2009-2020 que
vous aviez vous avez on est revenu sur
le Grenelle de l'environnement que vous
aviez poussé y compris au niveau
national comme au niveau européen avec
pour la première fois j'ai envie de dire
des ambitions fortes notamment en termes
de sobriété on en parle beaucoup
aujourd'hui mais vous étiez un des
premiers à le poser directement en
fonction de ministre en termes de
sobriété d'efficacité qui était
consolidées dans des plans et vous avez
même parlé de décroissance de la
consommation ce qui à l'époque avait en
fait un effet levier sur les mesures à
attendre vous êtes revenu sur quelque
part l'échec des objectifs puisque vous
avez fixé des objectifs dans des
feuilles de route qui étaient ambitieux
qui n'ont pas été atteints et ma
question c'est comment se fait-il que
alors que nous avions fixé des objectifs
de rénovation des bâtiments sur les
transports vous l'avez évoqué comment se
fait-il que nous n'avions pas que nous
n'avons pas atteint ces objectifs là et
une question annexe qu'on j'ai eu
l'habitude de poser à d'autres
auditionnées qui est on a été à un
moment donné du fait des installations
nucléaires fortes en France dans une
surcapacité de production et donc dans
un phénomène qui incitait plutôt à la
consommation électrique ou à vendre la
surconsommation électrique et donc on
est on voit ça a été rappelé aussi par
certains auditionnés dans la pointe
aujourd'hui
européenne la thermosensibilité pour 50%
et relative à la France qui fait là
aussi un sujet pour la dépendance et la
souveraineté énergétique de notre pays
comment analyser vous quelque part cet
échec de latente des objectifs qui on
sait bien diminuer la consommation
d'énergie et à un des premiers leviers
pour nous protéger nous rendre moins
dépendants
dépendants de l'extérieur ça c'est un
premier est-ce que c'était le pilotage
est-ce qu'il y a des moyens on avait
fait pas été mis en oeuvre
dans les commentaires y compris de la
Cour des comptes qui ont réalisé ce qui
s'est passé on a l'impression que on a
opté pour un chauffage décarboné plutôt
que de mieux isoler les bâtiments et les
logements avec les conséquences
aujourd'hui en termes de précarité
énergétique le deuxième la deuxième
question c'est sur la production des
énergies renouvelables là aussi dans le
paquet énergie climat et trois fois 20
au niveau européen vous aviez fixé des
ambitions de production d'énergie
renouvelables françaises qui n'ont
absolument pas été atteinte on est même
le seul État membre de l'Union
européenne à ne pas attendre nos
objectifs en matière d'énergie
renouvelable je sais pas si je continue
sur j'ai d'autres questions sur la
sûreté ou si je parce que c'est un volet
un peu à part sur la feuille de route
française et les moyens sur l'efficacité
énergétique la sobriété
les humains
dans ce cas-là sur le nucléaire
j'aimerais revenir notamment sur le
fiasco de Flamanville puisque vous avez
été au coeur du lancement ou du moins du
démarrage du chantier des nombreuses
personnalités que nous avons
auditionnées nous aurons confirmé qu'au
démarrage les travaux d'ingénierie et de
détails étaient à peine entamés qu'on a
changé enfin la gestion du projet en
tout cas industriel en tant que tel
n'était pas à répéter que les études de
sûreté ou encore de référentiel
d'exclusion de rupture était peu ou pas
encore engagés c'est également le
constat qu'a fait dans son rapport
monsieur Jean-Martin Folz comment se
fait-il qu'à l'époque que le
gouvernement auquel vous avez appartenu
n'a pas demandé une remise à plat
complète et pourquoi on a laissé
poursuivre pourquoi vous avez laissé
poursuivre aussi le chantier en l'état
notamment vis-à-vis de la sûreté mais
qui ont pris sur la sécurisation du
chantier
infini vous qui est également en tant
que ministre qui n’y avait pas de
nécessité à construire un troisième
réacteur EPR nucléaire après flamant
ville et panli je vous cite dans les
citations la question pourrait se poser
dans une logique de remplacement si
l'ASN n'autorise pas le prolongement de
la durée des centrales actuelles au-delà
de 40 ans puis la politique énergétique
consistera en 2020 à privilégier les
économies d'énergie et les énergies
renouvelables on voit bien qu'on est en
pleine actualité avec cette citation sur
les orientations la stratégie
énergétique de notre pays quel est votre
avis aujourd'hui aux situations et au
regard de la situation notamment du
l'EPR à Flamanville troisième question
porte sur la sûreté nucléaire puisque
après l'incident du Tricastin en 2008
vous avez solennellement demandé la une
remise à plat de l'information de la
transparence et des systèmes
d'évaluation des impacts et des déchets
des installations nucléaires vous aviez
donc considéré à l'époque que que les
analyses enfin c'est une question est-ce
que vous avez considéré à l'époque les
analyses et les études n'étaient pas à
la hauteur auparavant pour demander
cette remise à plat et suite à cet
incidence le Haut Comité pour la
transparence et l'information sur les
sécurités nucléaire vous avez remis le 7
novembre 2008 un avis sur le suivi radio
écologique des eaux autour des
installations nucléaires et sur la
gestion des anciens sites entreposage
des déchets radioactifs et je m'excuse
mais je n'ai pas réussi à remettre la
main sur ce rapport aussi j'aimerais
vous demander si vous pouvez en
présenter les principales conclusions et
recommandations que vous avez dû
recevoir et si elles ont été suivies des
faits ensuite d'autres incidences sont
survenus ensuite depuis vos fonctions
ministérielles sans parler bien sûr de
Fukushima et le constat font un grand
nombre de nos concitoyens moi la
première et que l'impact des rejets
radioactifs sur la santé
reste encore et beaucoup trop flou voir
inexistant est-ce que ces inquiétudes
sont légitimes comment améliorer encore
la transparence sur cet enjeu qui paraît
majeur et comprise sur l'acceptabilité
considérez-vous que la question des
impacts la trajectoire et des enjeux
économiques des déchets nucléaires sont
assez abordés dans les concertations et
les débats autour de notre avenir
énergétique parce qu'il nous semble que
c'est un angle assez mort dans ce qui
est décidé et discuté ouvertement voilà
le volet le paquet de mes questions
merci Madame la député monsieur le
ministre
pardon
sur le premier groupe de questions
paquet climat énergie et ambition
française
d'abord le paquet climat énergie qui
avait été préparé par les Allemands
a été adopté sous président françaises
donc c'était un investissement très très
lourd parce qu'une présence c'est 6 mois
il fallait aller convaincre les Polonais
qui m'expliquait qu'ils avaient 600 ans
de charbon quatre fois moins cher sous
les pieds enfin je veux dire bon donc
essaie je rappelle le premier texte
vraiment engageant
international
juste pour bon et on était c'était pas
plus facile parce que il y avait le
Grenelle qui avait eu une autorité
européenne c'était regarder il y avait
spaghetti voilà on était dans tout ça
il n'est
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que dans
l'action publique ça demande du suivi de
la conscience du suivi une évaluation
des écarts on les conneries en
permanence voilà
il y a pas une décision qui a des effets
comme ça automatique sur 10 ans ça
n'existe pas et vous vous adaptez en
permanence vous adaptez les tarifs de
rachat d'électricité en permanence les
technologies veulent donc c'est un
problème d'adaptation tout ce qui avait
été décidé dans lequel nous-mêmes a été
mis en place j'ai cité les quelques
illustrations mais tout ce qui relevait
de ce qu'on pouvait faire tout de suite
c'est-à-dire l'énorme bâtiments les oui
les échos artisans les échos les bonus
malus toutes ces décisions ont été
effectifs en revanche le suivi
notamment alors il y a deux sujets dans
ce que vous évoquez vous avez les les la
gestion thermique des bâtiments
alors sur les propriétés les individuels
il y a eu un début il y a eu beaucoup
des mobilisation des banques mutualistes
notamment Caisse d'Épargne Crédit Mutuel
Crédit Agricole qui ont beaucoup
beaucoup il y en a eu beaucoup
le parc HLM qui faisait et la rénovation
urbaine a fait la touffé c'est pas
parfait mais a fait la rénovation
thermique mais je pense que pour
l'avenir on a un sujet qui est passé de
la rénovation thermique pure à l'année
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments je
pense que là moi même j'ai répété
pendant des années un certain nombre de
vérité auquel je ne crois plus autant
aujourd'hui mais c'est une autre
question donc il faut demander à ceux
qui ont opéré après je veux dire voilà
ça c'était 2008 2010
c'est pas l'habitude de voir ce que font
mais mes successeurs
j'ai écouté dans des débats parce que je
me suis passionné par le travail de
cette commission j'ai appris en plus
vraiment des choses
l'idée qu'il y avait un espèce de lobby
de DF pour le tout électrique parce
qu'on était en surcapacité je sais pas
qui qui l'a dit
en matière d'énergie
moi je crois pas beaucoup le billet je
pense qu'il y a des intérêts parfois
contradictoires des gens qui s'expriment
pierre mon avis il y a une décision que
l'équipe et elle s'impose à tout le
monde je ne crois pas que EDF est tout
fait pour empêcher par exemple le
programme d'énergie renouvelable
d'ailleurs ils ont créé une filière qui
s'appelle EDF énergie nouvelle c'est la
mémoire est bonne je pense en revanche
que la culture française de l'époque où
on avait un réseau piloté stable pas
cher décarbonées un moment où les
derniers renouvelables étaient encore un
peu chers et pour certaines franchement
chers avec des problèmes de pilotage ben
ça mettait la France pas tout à fait
dans le même condition que d'autres pays
européens je crois que maintenant c'est
en train de changer et de changer très
très vite et c'est tant mieux mais je
pense que le retard est un retard
culturel lié à notre modèle énergétique
à notre climat
qui fait que l'hiver on a un peu moins
de chauffage que d'autres pays et il
était un peu moins climatisation que
d'autres pays donc le fait d'être dans
un climat tempéré vous vous poussez pas
les ruisse si je veux dire de manière
énergétique donc je peux pas vous dire
ce dont je suis certain en revanche
c'est que nous partons dans une période
où c'est l'électricité qui va devenir
dominante ça d'abord c'est simple pour
le CO2 le prix des tonnes de ce vont
continuer à augmenter donc le non pas
tout électrique mais l'électricité
pour des raisons d'indépendance de CO2
va prospérer je pense qu'on va
redécouvrir les vertus de la géothermie
et du géostockaz je rappelle que Paris
était chauffé
je termine enfin une partie de Paris au
siècle dernier et je me rends c'est un
circuit court la terre comme thermostat
oui c'est un thermos la terre 14 degrés
en fait c'est 14 un peu plus loin c'est
plus chaud etc donc je pense que le
circuit court de gestockage de je
termine je partage assez la vie du
commissaire au Plan fin de dernier
rapport du commissaire à au plan qui qui
suggère une centaine de terawan de
géostockage géothermique je pense que et
notre besoin électrique il va prendre 45
% d'ici la mise en route de toute façon
des prochains EPS je parle pas de
Flamanville mais de de l'hypothèse ou de
la décision des six prochains je pense
qu'on a une grosse difficulté le besoin
par l'évolution des besoins la
digitalisation les voitures électriques
à tout ce que vous savez aussi bien que
moi amen a besoin un article et je ne
vois pas d'autres solutions que donc les
circuits courts
que l'explosion
la réflexion sur les SMR je ne suis pas
sûr qu'on n'est pas laissé passer le
train je ne suis pas sûr que le projet
EDF avec une boîte américaine je sais
plus laquelle soit pas très en retard
par rapport au tandemstroyce Ji
qui ont déjà essayé des contrats en
Suède au Japon en Australie enfin bon
est-ce que est-ce que est-ce que il faut
pas revenir à l'hypothèse 69 accepter
une licence qui ne soit pas une
production française
et puis je crois que la révolution
digitale va impacter la révolution
énergétique je veux dire la
digitalisation de l'énergie la gestion
du réseau quand moi je quitte on doit
avoir à peu près enfin ces
responsabilités on devrait à peu près
2000 entrées sur le réseau donc ça
résout facilement pilotable
je peux pas vous dire de bêtises mais on
doit pas loin d'être à 400 à 500 000
aujourd'hui donc je dirais et le
renouvelable enfin il y a
d'intermittence
c'est comme ça
[Musique]
par une beaucoup plus grande performance
énergétique
vous m'aviez posé une question oui sur
la sécurité aux membres Flamanville je
vais vous dire les choses assez
simplement
quand le père de flamants ville ne fait
que démarrer enfin c'est on donne
l'autorisation d'une démarche après je
parle je suis pas mais je vous dis juste
la vérité mais je serais resté je ne
suis pas sûr que j'aurais la sagacité de
de de de
de commencer
à mettre en cause
ni le design qui avait été produit par
Framatome et si mince
ni la capacité d'EDF je pense qu'il
aurait fallu qu'il y ait des premiers
incidents je n'étais pas là mais je ne
parle presque pour mes successeurs
faut voir l'image de def enfin c'est une
très grande maison
sa capacité à construire EDF
construisait je rappelle des réacteurs
en 5 ans qui sont toujours en
fonctionnement donc il y a une il y a un
passé de EDF constructeurs qui plaide
largement pour moi je me pose beaucoup
plus la question du design beaucoup plus
la question de l'EPR le seul sujet qu'on
aborde jamais
je pense que voilà il y a de l'atome
parce que c'est des carboné et puis de
toute façon on n'a pas le choix et puis
des rendez-vous et l'intelligence
artificielle et l'efficacité énergétique
enfin mes enfants c'est pas Flamanville
le sujet c'est la Finlande c'est Tyson
s'est arrêté c'est c'est et si c'était
et si finalement l'histoire ne bégayait
pas parce que je rappelle que de 1900 60
ou 55 à 69 on a essayé des EPR enfin je
dis des EPR on a essayé des technologies
proposées par Framatome le CEA etc et
qui était pas mal d'ailleurs mais
finalement si on peut éthique c'était
non c'est trop sophistiqué cette
recherche
et donc on prend on est en plein épaule
gaulliste gollienne avec la sortie de
l'OTAN enfin donc c'était bon mais
c'était on a pris un truc robuste les
chinois vient de décider qui ne feront
plus de pairs
je suis pas en train de dire du mal je
me dis juste qu'un peuple est un pays a
le droit de s'arrêter sur l'ensemble de
sa stratégie y compris entre compte
parce que il y aurait eu un incident sur
un constructeur j'aime bien mais les
Européens ils ont pas été construits par
EDF donc
non je et même si j'étais assez trois
ans plus je suis pas sûr que j'aurais
spontanément mis en cause des voyez
c'est c'est voilà
ma réponse sur sur la sécurité est-ce
que j'ai oublié un point
alors
vous me rappelez ce souvenir je me
souviens très très bien alors s'il y
avait un truc qui m'a eu beaucoup frappé
à l'époque c'est la difficulté de
communication et d'information avec les
au comité Baconnière elle était
là-dessus
elle était là-dessus et je peux pas je
me souviens pas exactement sur quoi mais
je me souviens qu'on avait amélioré les
les conditions d'alerte de transparence
et avec les ONG d'ailleurs ont été assez
présentes et à juste titre et à juste
raison et faisait avait un pouvoir
d'alerte extrêmement fort à l'époque
j'étais très très présentes dans le
débat sur la transparence très présente
et c'était une bonne chose franchement
sur le rapport
si je crois pas que je retrouverai mais
si je le retrouve enfin on va forcément
le retrouver quelque part dans les
archives de l'État français et vous
pouvez demander à la Ministre en charge
où les deux puisque c'est un peu confus
enfin en tout cas c'est partager pardon
de répondre à la question sincèrement je
vous dirai des bêtises et comme j'ai
joué de te dire de bêtises
merci Monsieur la parole au rapporteur
si monsieur le Président merci monsieur
le ministre monsieur barlou pour ses
premiers éléments
peut-être
pour nous replonger dans le contexte de
l'époque et éviter les anachronismes
vous pouvez nous dire dans quel état
vous avez trouvé
y compris en matière de gouvernance
la politique énergétique française en
arrivant aux responsabilités parce et
puis peut-être nous rappeler aussi vos
attributions parce que sauf erreur dans
le gouvernement Fillon 1 le ministre
d'Etat n'est en charge que de l'écologie
et il devient en charge de l'énergie
après les élections législatives il n'y
a pas de de ministre ou de secrétaire
d'État en charge directement de
l'énergie et quelques temps après la
direction générale de l'énergie
traditionnellement au sein de
l'industrie à Bercy devient une
direction du ministère de
l'Environnement donc peut-être d'abord
en termes de gouvernance et puis aussi
en termes d'ambiance dans les grands
choix qui avait été faits dans les
dernières années dans quel état vous
trouvez les politiques publiques en la
matière
mais je n'ai pas ce souvenir
si la deuxième question la première j'ai
pas souvenir qu'il y a eu modification
de l'architecture
gouvernementale je me souviens qui est
un changement de titulaire
à l'injupé a quitté ce ministère et je
l'ai remplacé
mais
j'ai pas le souvenir qui est une
extension plus tard deux ans après non
non il y a eu une modification mais pour
ajouter la mer et les océans et les
négociations climat
mais ce qui fait de blocage c'est un
type qui a fini par mais
c'est pas souvenir de m'en veuillez pas
mais pour répondre maintenant sur le
fond de votre question
j'allais dire de à l'époque aujourd'hui
parce que
c'est vraiment et je reviens ici
là-dessus c'est
si on va au fond des choses vous verrez
qu'il y a un consensus
la preuve le Grenelle il n'y a pas eu de
Casus Belli sur le nucléaire
avec les ONG parce que on est allé sur
un fond on n'était pas parti pour faire
développement du nucléaire débridé pas
du tout d'ailleurs on l'expliquait un
petit à petit sera remplacé par les
renouvelables etc et on faisait des gros
efforts d'efficacité énergétique
pour ça il faut qu'il y a un pilote
moi je voudrais surtout pas
me fâcher avec qui que ce soit mais
c'est très compliqué quand dans un pays
vous avez le ministère des Finances
l'économie du budget
qui est qui a
un niveau de compétence interne
incroyablement puissant élevé qui a
quasiment une direction générale qui
double chaque ministère le logement
l'énergie bon qui en plus un dans son
sein culturel
l'Agence des participations de l'État
qui a une stratégie pardon de le dire le
mot n'est pas vulgaire de banquier
d'affaires enfin je veux dire de
gestionnaire des actifs
devronter des dividendes par exemple ou
de coups ou de bouclier tarifaire etc
je pense que il faut absolument et pour
répondre à votre question
oui je pense que en 10 ou 15 ans
l'énergie est peu à peu passer sous
l'influence de Bercy au détriment
j'allais dire des des ingénieurs de
corps des mines des ponts enfin de la
partie production française classique
alors est-ce que c'est l'effet d'avoir
remis les écologies énergies dans le
même ministère
écoutez je n'en sais rien non je pense
que ça parce que c'est vrai dans le
logement c'est vrai à peu près partout
notre pays aujourd'hui administré depuis
ce magnifique bâtiment qui a un pied
dans la scène je ne sais pas quelle
autorisation environnementale d'ailleurs
bon mais
il y a une perte de puissance politique
de ce ministère ça c'est une absolue
certitude que je n'ai pas ressenti à
l'époque
j'étais entravé par personne le mystère
de l'économie on a eu des moments de
mais on n'a pas eu de tension mais à
l'époque il y avait un signal
c'était j'étais sûrement pas le plus
brillant de cette génération mais
j'étais ministre d'État
de la volonté d'un président de la
République dans le cadre d'une élection
présidentielle donc ça a donné pardon un
poids j'ajoute que le Grenelle de
l'environnement donner un poids à la
parole de ce ministère au delà de
l'individu donner un point le paquet
clim énergie donné un point donc c'était
un ministère puissant passionné par ça
je pense qu'on était d'ailleurs plus
plus sur cette balle là que sur la
biodiversité par exemple je pense que on
a fait les armoires protégées
vous êtes focus sur des trucs sujets
c'est ce cela nous c'est tellement
énorme avouer semblable donc ma
conviction absolue c'est qu'il y a
besoin y compris aujourd'hui d'un débat
en profondeur et peut-être que le
travail est incroyable de cette
commission peut y contribuer sur une
stratégie à 50 ans par étape de 10 ans
puis de 5 ans puis trimestrielle voilà
et et là le découpage actuel me paraît
ne pas donner la pleine puissance au à
ce sujet de l'énergie de l'efficacité
énergétique et c'est pas
grave ne pas faire de
politiciennes je sais pas du tout mon
sujet on essaie des trucs dans la vie
c'est c'est parce que à l'inverse la
concept de planification est un concept
intelligent vous voyez donc je suis pas
du tout dans la critique mais je pense
qu'on peut se poser ce problème et le
problème de c'est quoi le est-ce que le
nucléaire en France c'est ou le père ou
rien
alors justement puisque vous avez évoqué
le Grenelle de l'environnement
effectivement le candidat Nicolas
Sarkozy
promettait je cite une révolution
écologique et donc une fois élue et
après avoir remporté les élections
législatives ce manque le Grenelle
devant de l'environnement donc vous avez
la charge et dont on comprend que le
nucléaire est exclu des débats alors je
vous allez nous vous allez nous dire
parce que on a eu des versions un peu un
peu différentes et je citerai simplement
celle d'Henri Proglio selon lequel le
nucléaire avait été exclu des débats
volontairement par Nicolas Sarkozy pour
éviter justement d'avoir un débat qui se
focaliserait sur le sujet et qui ne
permettrait pas de donner la place de
fait dans les débats et vous me
contredirez si je me si je me trompe le
nucléaire est fort peu présent
notamment eugar à sa place dans le mix
électrique français et au fait que c'est
une énergie d'une énergie décarbonée
est-ce que vous pouvez peut-être nous
retracer le la place importante moins
importante la proportion du clair dans
les débats du Grenelle de
l'environnement
quand vous faites
vous proposer le Grenelle de
l'environnement
mais les gens sont pas convoqués
c'est une démarche volontaire accepter
avec des règles avec des ONG
représentant d'autres c'est tout un
processus démocratique par exemple
et il n'y a il n'y aurait pas eu de
poursuite du Grenelle si on n'avait pas
abandonné la montagne d'or en Guyane
là c'est un mais c'est pas c'est pas
nous qui fixons le cadre il faut bien un
moment donné que tout le monde soit
d'accord et donc d'un certain
consensus
ce qui ne vaut pas validation des
stratégies nucléaires par les ONG mais
on pouvait faire le Grenelle en disant
voilà nous notre feuille de route ça va
être ça globalement c'est tolérable
voilà donc c'est pas qu'il y a eu ça a
été exclu si les ONG trouver que il
devait y avoir il y aurait pas eu de
Grenelle c'est aussi simple que ça mais
ça a été vrai sur les pesticides sur
plein de sujets donc c'est le Grenelle
ça pas été de du marchandage c'est des
milliers d'heures avec des experts pour
aller au fond des choses ma conviction
de fond dans l'action publique c'est
qu'il y a beaucoup plus de malentendus
que de désaccord si on travaille
scientifiquement technologiquement de
bonne foi et au fond des choses on
arrive à trouver des axes de progrès
commun
pas si j'ai répondu à votre question
si absolument avant d'enchaîner sur
d'autres questions sur le
sur les prix électricité sur le
nucléaire je voulais vous poser une
question
sur les concessions droélectriques je la
pose maintenant il y a pas de bonne
ordre pour la poser mais on a énormément
parlé ici de la mise en concurrence des
constitutions hydroélectriques et de la
situation de flottement qu'on connaît
depuis lors et qui donne l'impression
que la France a accepté le principe pour
se mettre en conformité avec les
engagements européens mais n'a jamais
accepté en pratique que ce soit le cas
et je crois ce contrôle de mes collègues
qui ont assisté à nos autres auditions
que personne n'en a exprimé non a
exprimé le souhait pourtant vous
Présentez-vous même en juillet 2008 un
plan pour les concessions
hydroélectriques qui comportent leur
mise en concurrence donc ma question est
simple est-ce que vous y étiez favorable
ou est-ce que vous y avez été contraint
et considéré que on allait au pouvoir
l'éviter en pratique
ou trouver des contournements
les deux
en vérité mais oui la vérité c'est
celle-là d'abord on est dans un état de
droit
et il y a des concurrents
qui ont également des droits il y avait
des prétentieux et je rappelle que eDF
n'a pas 100 % des concessions
hydrauliques on doit avoir 80 ou 75 ou
80 je sais plus mais enfin bon il y
avait une première bataille avec avec la
CNR c'est ma mémoire est bonne pour
éviter un contentieux qui était
extrêmement violent donc au fond les
avis étaient sensiblement partagés on
est dans un état droit et la concession
éternelle ou on remet dans le domaine
public directement les barafes les
concessions mais EDF société anonyme de
toute façon un jour ou l'autre attrapé
par la patrouille simplement il y a pas
de visibilité il y a pas donc il y avait
cette idée que dans un état droit on se
conforme je rajoute que la pression de
la commission là-dessus elle était vraie
elle est toujours vrai aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs bon ce qu'on a fait c'est
qu'on a préparé au cas où bon on a on en
a déclenché en vérité aucune le chantier
il est resté en l'état
c'est pas ce qui serait passé si j'étais
resté deux ou trois ans de plus on a
préparé un décret
qui prépare la procédure si on doit le
mettre en concurrence le mais c'est pas
des clés qui diront mais en concurrence
voilà posez on gagne un peu de temps si
on se dit les choses franchement on
gagne un peu de temps on y voit Patrick
clair il y a du courrier du compte il y
a des avis très partagés y compris je
rappelle dans les territoires les élus
locaux parce que c'est aussi un revenu
partiel des élus locaux donc
la la
j'allais dire l'état de de l'opinion
français n'était pas tranchée et on
l'avait pas tranché en vrai voilà on
avait un peu gainé temps on était sorti
dans l'ensemble des contentieux on était
ravis et puis on allait voir bon et puis
il y avait les problèmes de passage de
poisson enfin il y avait des il y avait
des premiers écologistes assez
écologique assez compliqué dans le cadre
des éventuels renouvellement tout ça
était est-ce que c'était le prix qu'il
devait primer ou la sécurité est-ce que
la dimension environnementale quel était
le coefficient c'est pas abouti voilà la
vérité c'est que moi quand je suis parti
on n'avait pas fait le boulot
excusez-moi si je résume et je vous me
corrigerai mais ce que je comprends
c'est que vous y étiez favorable et vous
avez tenté d'en amenuiser les
conséquences les plus dommageables
est-ce que je peux faire acte d'humilité
maintenant non
non mais
autant sur tout le reste j'avais des
convictions extrêmement acquises en
travaillant autant là franchement il y
avait les arguments des deux côtés mais
on était plus préoccupés par l'idée que
ce serait inéluctable parce que dans un
état de droit une SA ne peut pas avoir
de concessions perpétuelle et donc si on
doit le faire voyons tous les problèmes
environnementaux les problèmes des
sécurités voilà on était plus préoccupés
par ça
il y avait un caractère un peu
inéluctable mais pas souhaitable c'est
pas très courageux mais c'est la vérité
je remercie non non je pense qu'on est
tous très content de pouvoir faire acte
de lucidité
j'en viens à quelques quelques questions
sur le marché européen forcément
peut-être vous avez déjà dit beaucoup de
choses et puis compris en réponse aux
questions mais
peut-être nous redire votre sentiment
sur la sur la question de la concurrence
sur le marché européen de l'électricité
de manière générale si vous aviez parce
que les débats avaient été largement
lancé la mise en concurrence et
effective et donc peut-être votre votre
conviction lorsque vous arrivez au
responsabilités et puis quand même un
mot sur le déroulement des travaux de la
commission Champsaur et sur le choix qui
est fait de l'arène effectivement avec
beaucoup d'humilité aujourd'hui enfin
avec parfois peu d'humilité d'ailleurs
on remet en cause des choix de l'époque
et on a l'impression que c'était une
évidence mais nous aider à comprendre
comment on peut se retrouver dans une
situation où on fixe un tarif qui
manifestement correspond au calcul des
administrations enfin de vos
administrations 42 euros
42 euros comprenant les Fukushima enfin
les les impératifs post Fukushima et
puis à votre époque 40 euros
mais qui ne convient pas du tout à EDF
aux responsable de l'époque et actuelle
qui lui attribue la quasi-totalité des
difficultés financières n'oubliez pas de
tes vagues d'EDF mais je pense que vous
aurez quelque chose à dire là-dessus
donc à la fois sur le montant et puis
sur la question de l'option comment se
fait-il qu'on est prévu une option
asymétrique est-ce que finalement on
considérait que les prix ne pourraient
jamais être tel que ce serait que ce
serait louable d'avoir une symétrie ou
est-ce qu'il y a une autre raison qui a
présidé au fait que la reine soit
asymétrique c'est-à-dire que
DF soit contrainte de proposer ce tarif
mais que les fournisseurs alternatifs ne
soient pas eux contraints de l'acheter à
ce tarif
alors je parle dans quel ordre vous
commencez par par ça
je vous rappelle qu'on a des contentieux
en France perdu que le conseil de l'État
nous donne tant que le Conseil
constitutionnel aussi qu'on a deux
directives européennes et on a deux
procédures en infraction et on a les
professionnels qui nous disent toute
façon votre truc il est provisoire votre
Tartane il s'appelle d'ailleurs
provisoire le tarif jour le tarif
et il y a des grands énergéticiens qui
veulent investir dans notre pays dit
mais on peut pas parce que le système il
est bouclé bon
avouez que la situation est bon alors il
y a plusieurs façons il y avait une
façon parce que qui a été envisagée
d'ailleurs et dire ben on sort du marché
européen et puis voilà et puis il y aura
pas de il y aura pas de concurrence
c'est bien comme ça c'est une notion qui
a été étudiée
je peux vous le dire sérieusement étudié
ce qui a à peine étudié
c'est presque voilà c'est évacué assez
rapidement ils vont plus parler eux du
démantèlement en disant pour qu'il y ait
de la concurrence il faut qu'il y ait
des parties d'activités qui soient
morcelés et comme ça on va introduire de
la concurrence et puis il y a ce que je
vous disais la taxation pour permettre
aux alternatives d'investir dans ce que
l'objectif c'était d'augmenter la
capacité je rappelle c'est quand même ça
l'objectif principal et maintenir
l'avantage compétitif quand le
consommateur français bon
donc cette composition je rappelle des
parlementaires de tout bord des experts
de tout mort qui arrivent à l'unité à
une proposition provisoire en disant
attention elle est transitoire
2025 si ma mémoire est bonne maximum
mais on l'a révalu tous les ans
parce que c'est extrêmement bien de dire
la voiture là vous avez une voiture vous
la mettez faites rouler mais il y a
personne au volant bah il va se passer
quelque chose dans un virage c'est à peu
près clair c'est un système de pilotage
permanent le prix doit être fixé je le
rappelle pour le financement du parc
nucléaire français d'EDF son
amortissement
les grosses réparations le démantèlement
et le grand carénage
et on devait vérifier à chaque fois donc
ça c'est pardon que je sache toutes ces
données bougent bah non le tarif il
bouge pas
pourquoi il bouge pas le tarif parce
qu'en réalité tout allait très bien je
dirais 45 ans ça allait très très bien
EDF il y a le plus de consciencieux plus
d'emmerdement plus de restitution pas
plus de bagages c'est les l'infractions
en
net d'État enfin je veux dire ça va donc
tout le monde était assez grand ça
commence à plus aller du tout quand les
prix Go se mettent à exploser et que
effectivement du coup
on ne suspend pas là on modifie pas le
tarif on se sent parce que qu'est-ce qui
nous empêche de suspendre la reine à ce
moment-là rien
on ne suspend pas on subit une explosion
du marché de gros qui rentre du coup la
même pas piloté c'est aussi moi je ne
suis pas sûr que c'était il y a
peut-être il y avait peut-être
meilleures décisions mais j'encourage un
travail sérieux pour
2025 ça doit commencer dès maintenant
parce que j'observe que on vient
d'étendre la reine à 120 terawatts à 46
euros comme quoi on pouvait tout bouger
non mais c'est une blague cette histoire
vous pouvez pas avoir un véhicule de
sortie de crise qui permet la
concurrence qui vous permet de sortir
des contentieux qui apaissent tout un
secteur et la laisser comme ça rouler
tout seul son pilote ça ça n'existe pas
donc c'est un
une rustine de l'instant je n'ai pas
peur des mots qui étaient je crois
pertin en tous les cas qui devait être
piloté et suspendu à tout instant mais
ça rejoint votre question sur le marché
européen c'est exactement la même
situation pardon mais qu'est-ce qui
empêchait de suspendre le prix de
l'électricité des mars 2022 quand il y a
l'explosion du Sud à l'agression
ukrainienne
dans les textes nous prévois de
suspendre provisoirement
le le
la corrélation entre non pas le prix du
gaz mais le prix de la dernière centrale
donc c'est en fait le prix du gaz bon
et pour vous dire la vérité bien que je
sois un convaincu
je suis plus interrogatif aujourd'hui
sur le marché européen de l'énergie je
veux dire parce que ce qu'on voit quand
même clairement parce que les choses
évoluent on a un bloc de pays
qui a une stratégie gazière
gazières
renouvelable 0 nucléaire et limite
nous on a une stratégie nucléaire
et renouvelable et sur le renouvelable
de 2 essentiellement parce que sur
l'hydroélectricité on est à peu près au
top quoi enfin on va pas en faire
beaucoup plus bon et peut-être
l'hydrolienne enfin bon
c'est quand même avoir un prix fixé le
gros fixé sur
une énergie
cible d'un pays dominant
d'ailleurs on a bien vu que sur la
taxonomie on a accepté qu'il y ait des
avancées parce qu'on était le gaz avec
ça mérite très une réflexion très
approfondie pardon on peut faire de
l'interconnexion physique
sans avoir un marché complètement libre
d'ailleurs pardon dans les événements de
l'époque qui expliquaient l'ensemble un
peu de l'accord finalement tolérance en
tous les cas on avait fait les
interconnexions avec l'Espagne je
rappelle sous les Pyrénées un énorme
travail dans un tunnel etc donc on peut
faire de l'interconnexion
[Musique]
ouais
moi je suis
plus réservé aujourd'hui sur parce que
un prix commun sur des énergies
dissociées dissociation et radicalement
opposés
il faut en tout cas quelqu'un regarde
bien le pilotage de ça parce qu'on a
bien vu que là il y a eu un problème de
pilatage parce que on laisse le truc
monter on met le bouclier enfin je veux
dire bon donc c'est pour ça que c'est un
peu la même chose vous trouverez jamais
un mécanisme parfait en matière
d'énergie jamais parce que il y a du
long terme des investissements lourds il
y a la protection du consommateur il y a
la concurrence c'est complexe mais en
tous les cas ça doit être piloté ça doit
être dans la distance mais piloter en
permanence
alors justement puisque vous parlez de
une question européenne et de cible
européenne
la France pourrait être sujette à des
amendes pour ne pas atteindre ses
objectifs des objectifs qui sont fixés
de longue date et vous en avez été l'un
des instigateurs en 2008 vous disiez je
vous cite je ne crois pas que ce soit le
rôle de l'Europe d'orienter le bouquet
énergétique de tel ou tel État membre
même si de plus en plus de pays
s'accordent pour reconnaître que le
nucléaire peut jouer un rôle pour autant
il n'y a pas qu'une seule réponse
comment est-ce que vous jugez
aujourd'hui le fait qu'on est au niveau
européen des objectifs d'énergie
renouvelables qui ne dépendent
finalement pas du niveau de
décarbonation ou en tout cas du niveau
d'émission de gaz à effet de serre du
système énergétique national de chaque
pays
je pense que c'est une erreur mais
vraiment
c'est pour ça que le principe même de
marcher régulier par la commission si
j'ose dire me paraît pas adapté oui
c'est vrai que c'est vrai que on n'a pas
respecté un accord comme ça faut mettre
d'accord 27 pays c'est pas c'est pas
votre position point final donc ça avait
été négocié par les Allemands et c'est
nous qui l'avions défendu et fait voter
mais mais je trouverai absolument normal
et logique donc qu'il y ait une
discussion avec la commission sur cette
affaire-là ça me paraît pas raisonnable
l'idée d'une ça veut pas dire que on a
raison de traîner c'est presque je veux
dire mais à partir du moment où il y a
voilà à des engagements assez assez
clair assez ferme assez puissant pour
rattraper ce retard à l'allumage
parce que c'est pour moi un retard
l'allumage culturel je pense que il y a
une discussion forcément possible avec
la coalition
je vous remercie de deux ou trois
questions peut-être
une sur
[Musique]
une sur la quatrième génération dans
l'autre sens je commence par les 4e la
troisième cela quatrième génération pour
comprendre
quel est l'état des discussions lorsque
vous êtes au responsabilité parce que
la loi récemment lorsque vous arrivez au
responsabilités la loi a depuis peu
ancré un objectif de travailler sur la
4e génération
et en 2010
alors que comment dirais-je et donc en
2010 le projet Astrid est lancé alors
finalement qu'on n'a pas encore ouvert
de réacteurs de 3e génération est-ce que
c'est à dire que sous ce quinquennat la
motivation de enfin la volonté d'avancer
sur la filière nucléaire et de garder
pour longtemps une filière nucléaire y
compris une filière capable d'absorber
ses propres déchets puisque c'était l'un
des enjeux et forte quel est le degré à
l'époque de de d'optimisme ou de ou de
d'inquiétude à la fois sur la quatrième
génération et du coup sur la troisième
c'est est-ce que vous faites un lien
entre les deux est-ce que vous il y a
une inquiétude qui se formule du fait
même c'est pas du tout les mêmes stades
de recherche et de développement et
d'industrialisation mais qui se
formulent sur la quatrième et à rebours
sur la troisième génération qui elle
accumule les retards
à l'époque on était assez confiant
franchement
notre pays avait des retards pas mal de
domaines peut-être mais pas ce sentiment
dans celui-là et donc le SMS
on
ITER par exemple cet enfant c'est un
cadration on peut discuter d'Hitler sa
performance ça pertinence mais enfin en
étant l'idée compris de fusion de
fission de troisième de quatrième de SMS
l'avance française sur le nucléaire des
sous-marins de la DCNS on investissait
surtout en même temps
c'est ça qu'il faut bien comprendre donc
il y avait pas de choix de l'un plus tôt
que de l'autre et on réfléchissait par
votre conséquence à pas forcément
d'autres EPR que
Flamanville au fond dans l'inconscient
collectif c'était ça c'était oui il y
avait un saut mais ça peut être beaucoup
plus petit du SMS ça peut être 3e
génération 4e génération voilà c'était
bon cool les gars allez-y travailler
fait des recherches investissez c'était
le grand emprunt est en partie venu de
là
en partie je suis pas seulement en
partie venue de la 1 2 de 20 milliards
si vous vous souvenez donc oui il y
avait une confiance dans dans
l'évolution technologique oui
merci et ma dernière question elle porte
parce que ça a été un acteur en creux de
vos propos sur EDF
auditionner de nombreux responsables en
sa responsable de DF qui au-delà de la
reine nous en parlait du niveau des prix
et notamment Pierre gadennec qui a été
en fonction pendant une partie de votre
mandat qui est évoqué le fait que il
avait militait auprès des autorités
politiques dont j'imagine que vous
faisiez partie dans son raisonnement sur
le fait de dire que les prix étaient
trop bas pour permettre à EDF de
préparer le renouvellement enfin la
bonne maintenance puis le renouvellement
de son parc et d'investir dans les
différentes dans les différentes
facettes de son activité
et en même temps vous êtes confrontés
comme ministre en charge de l'énergie à
EDF et au projet EPR qu'est-ce qui dans
le dans la gouvernance générale entre
l'État et EDF et dans votre appréciation
de l'entreprise EDF a pu manquer à
l'époque est-ce que c'est une vision de
long terme est-ce que c'est le fait que
ce n'était plus tout à fait comme avant
la transformation en sa est-ce qu'il y
avait d'autres facteurs qui ont joué
est-ce que c'était une question de
personnes c'est pas le but de cette
commission de déterminer des
responsabilités personnelles mais je
pose la question de manière la plus
large possible pour essayer de savoir ce
qui est à votre sens vous qui avez été
en contact pendant plusieurs années avec
l'opérateur principal a pu
faire qu'il y ait une sorte de surdité
dans le dialogue entre DF et l'État EDF
se plaignant d'une inadéquation par la
suite du tarif à Rennes EDF se plaignant
de tarifs trop bas et à l'inverse ce
n'étant pas capable de livrer un
réacteur
rien qu'on essaie de toujours de trouver
des causes simples mais pardon de vous
dire que
le sujet de d'EDF c'était pas son prix
c'était pas le tarif c'était pas si
finance qui était florissante
j'ai entendu dire que pouvoir faire une
clipoint 15 milliards c'était attendez
constellation ça a coûté combien
les achats aux États-Unis c'est un côté
combien non mais c'est une blague le
sujet d'EDF c'était arrivé
la vérité c'est que EDF
estimait et je peux le comprendre qui
avait un chef de fil du nucléaire en
France c'était EDF et que arriva était
un fournisseur de DF alors si j'en ai
pas entendu là si j'en ai pas entendu
parler je veux bien mourir ça a été
quotidien ça
et c'est allé enfin vous souvenez pas
des polémiques
incessantes
de part et d'autre entre Areva et et les
préoccupations c'était la sortie de
cymes pardon du projet up ça c'est un
sujet enfin je rappelle que le père est
conçu par Siemens et Franco
le partenaire allemand s'en va et ça
alors ça c'est pas un problème ça
non mais c'est
pas une peut vraiment parler de deux
minutes il ne crée pas une tant que
c'est un investissement financier porté
par tiers avec les autorités
britanniques présentent au capital et
garantissant les empreintes c'est un
dossier et dans lequel EDF est
minoritaire
son est un autre quand les autorités
britanniques ne sont plus actionnaires
qu'elles ne garantissent plus les
emprunts et que et donc on le consolide
on le porte dans le bilan d'EDF pardon
la black 14 milliards
et on décide de construire quand même je
rappelle la démission du directeur
financier de DF de Thomas pickman ce
jour-là
disons que ça mettait en paix donc il
n'y a pas eu de sonner parce que ce
n'était pas un sujet
voilà c'était c'est
pas de souvenirs de réunions en tous des
cas emportés après on peut toujours bon
non et et le seul moment c'était quand
sont sortis des chiffres de l'arène
alors à 32 34 36 37 oui mais d'ailleurs
les parlementaires étaient sur la même
et je vous retrouverai dans les débats
Daniel Paul qui est pas le suspect de ne
pas soutenir
EDF
disons répondant d'ailleurs à François
Brotte ou
dans les débats parlementaires que à 42
euros franchement c'est bien pour EDF
donc ce jour-là c'était bien
à d'autres jours cette épreuments trop
élevé quand les prix de cours étaient
complètement effondré et mais quand ils
ont explosé ça n'avait aucun sens et de
toute façon il est pas imaginable que
ayant progressé de quasi 15 ans
les conditions de fixation du prix qui
sont je rappelle l'entretien le grand
carénage le démantèlement encore une
quoi qu'il arrive vous pouvez pas rester
au même prix c'est pas possible
donc non je n'ai pas de souvenir de
que ça enfin c'était un sujet absolument
central si par exemple sur
l'hydroélectricité oui par exemple vous
aviez à la fois
enji ou compagnon
parce que c'est une société anonyme elle
monopole oui et élève qui est je garde
mes conseils oui ça oui ça je me
souviens bien mais pas ce que vous
évoquez pas de cas pas de manière
significative
je vous remercie une dernière question
de l'ancien député Borlo qui s'offe
assister au débat de la loi de 2015
qui a fixé un certain nombre d'objectifs
c'était bien débuté en 2015
je crois que c'est mes
pour moi si ce n'est pas le cas mais non
effectivement pardon vous voulez plus en
avril 2014 autant pour moi alors je pose
quand même question à
l'ancien ministre et aux citoyens sur la
loi de 2015 tout à l'heure Dominique
Maillard en sein directeur général de
l'énergie ancien président de RTE
indiqué qu'il y avait selon lui dans
cette loi une difficulté c'était la
multiplicité d'objectifs potentiellement
contradictoires ou en tout cas qui
pouvait se gêner les uns les autres
typiquement la baisse de des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre et un mix
énergétique avec une répartition
nucléaire énergie renouvelable
des effets sur la capacité à produire de
l'énergie et de l'efficacité énergétique
et de la sobriété est-ce que vous pensez
que dans cette loi et dans d'autres
objectifs passés on a eu difficulté à
avoir une stratégie un peu intégrée ou
une priorisation de nos objectifs
typiquement baisser les gaz à effet de
serre les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre et donc typiquement réduire notre
dépendance au fossile
avant tout et notamment avant de
répartir la charge entre nucléaire et
énergie renouvelables ou pas du tout
est-ce que pour vous c'est problématique
et ce qui a eu pour vous par exemple une
opposition entre nucléaire renouvelé et
renouvelable qui est dommageable ou
finalement au vu de votre expérience non
je
n'ai pas je n'ai pas souvenir de
une fois de plus je me reconstituais
physiquement et c'est pas vraiment suivi
mais je peux répondre plus généralement
dans ce domaine la somme des contraintes
est naturellement élevée et elle est
phasée et elle peut être contradictoire
un certain moment c'est une absolue
évidence le demande des renouvelable il
est payé sur les factures du
consommateur français même celui qui est
pas renouvelable à côté de l'huile CSPE
ça sert à ça et il y a pour le moment
une c'est une des raisons aussi du
retard à l'allumage au départ du système
français bon ça me paraît évident
maintenant ce que je
voudrais juste évoquer un point sur le
rapporteur sur le Président c'est
la nouvelle cartographie du monde de
l'énergie
moins il me semble qu'il y a devant nous
deux révolutions
la première je vous l'ai dit mais qui
est monstrueuse et qui peut être
extraordinaire pour nous c'est le retour
à la terre et la révolution digitale
énergétique
les progrès peuvent être mais
considérables regardez le succès
extraordinaire de cette fabuleuse
initiative de RTE qui est écoët
mais c'est une application digitale plus
récente mais on peut faire sans que le
pilotage à distance de l'énergie
pilotage intelligent le pilote agent
continu enfin on est encore dans un
passé préhistorique ou en gros il y a de
la production il y a de la consommation
un peu stable on allume en tant c'est
normal ça vient mais entre les deux
et le deuxième c'est ce qui se passe
à notre Sud
la nouvelle carte pour moi elle est Sud
elle est marocaine elle est sarienne
elle est mauritanienne elle est elle est
de cette partie c'est le macheray plus
les pays limitrophes ce qui est en train
de se passer mais c'est extravagant le
Sahara Occidental va devenir le hub
Energétique mondial du renouvelable
le l'hydrogène vert il sera à Carla
on a les interconnexions
je pense que
ce qui entraîne d'ailleurs une réflexion
plus globale de la France par rapport là
géopolitique
il y a un sujet qui a une influence
géopolitique sa robe si longtemps
notamment mais ne passons pas à côté de
cette redistribution géographique des
capacités
notre avenir est à notre Sud c'est ça ma
conviction pardon de répondre à une
question qu'on m'a pas posé
merci Monsieur Miss je vais passer la
parole de notre collègue Maxime leney
bonjour et merci monsieur borlot vous
avez répondu déjà un certain nombre de
questions si je peux faire j'en ai
quatre assez précise mais si je peux le
faire en deux fois en deux blocs la
première alors vous avez déjà longuement
évoqué flamant ville mais pour être un
peu précis par rapport à des
auditions que nous avons déjà amené
notamment le PDG d'EDF renouvelable et
quatre représentants de fédérations
syndicales hier qui nous ont dit pas
tout à fait la même chose le premier
nous a dit qu'en fait on avait lancé le
père de Flamanville tout simplement
parce que ça faisait 40 ans qu'on avait
pas construit de nouveaux réacteur et
qu'on se rendait compte qu'il fallait
quand même entretenir les compétences et
que c'était une façon de le faire et les
syndicalistes qu'on a rencontré hier
nous ont dit vous n'êtes pas du tout en
fait le père de Flamanville c'est juste
un prototype et donc fallait se faire la
main ce qui revient peut-être d'ailleurs
à peu près au même mais voilà donc si
vous avez des informations là dessus et
deuxième question pour ce premier bloc
ma collègue Judy learnos vous l'avez
posé mais c'est vrai qu'elle avait posé
beaucoup de questions c'est sur la
question des des déchets nucléaires
alors on pourrait parler de Cigéo mais
là on a appris il y a quatre jours et
que nos entreprises ont laissé les
entreprises françaises on va dire
ont laissé 20 millions de tonnes je
crois de déchets nucléaires à l'air
libre Niger est-ce que à l'époque vous
aviez connaissance de ces choses et
voilà et donc je reprendrai la parole si
ça vous dérange pas pour un autre sujet
alors sur la deuxième
j'aimerais parler franchement
ni à l'époque des mêmes
[Musique]
bah ça se serait entendu et vu quand
même c'est
sur
le père de flamant
une confiance totale dans EDF qui avait
qui construisait des réacteurs qui
marchaient toujours en 5 ans avec 100
sans dépassement de coupe donc
alors le One de la compétence
est un sujet dont on parlait à l'époque
ça c'est exact et et alors non je dirais
pas qu'on a fait enfin Mondeville parce
qu'il fallait que papa de la cohérence
de toute façon il y avait un petit sujet
quand même un nombre de parcs qui bon et
donc
bon ça c'était
un prix du temps je vous rappelle entre
2004 la première enfin quand EDF a fait
clairement cette proposition c'est en
2004 je crois enfin 2003 depuis 2004 moi
passer un peu de temps
mais la démographie de la compétence
était un sujet de préoccupation
effectivement à l'époque
et c'est pour cette raison
que quand est décédé panique
il y avait deux candidats
il y avait GDF Suez associé à
bon à consortium et EDF
et si on a confié à EDF accepte à
l'époque le seul argument qui dont je me
souviens enfin qui était pertinent c'est
on n'a pas construit depuis 25 ans
on a perdu des compétences en interne
en nous sous-traitant aussi
on a un problème donc on peut pas avoir
deux entités de compétences on y
arrivera pas voilà donc il y avait un
sujet de compétence mais plutôt sous cet
angle là
merci alors deuxième blog de questions
c'est sur EDF son statut sur les
privatisations etc
sur la séparation alors ça c'est un peu
antérieur à vos prises de fonction si je
dis pas de bêtises mais là c'est pas
ration EDF RTE enedis
hier les représentants syndicaux ont
bien rappelé que l'électricité c'est un
système il faut le voir sous cet angle
là la critique du marché que vous avez
fait aussi va dans ce sens là vous avez
rappelé que il y a un enjeu de
pilotabilité donc ça nous rappelle ça
nous rappelle ça nous ramène pardon à la
question du système vous avez rappelé
que on est passé de 2000 entrées
peut-être 400 000 entrées sur le réseau
donc première question est-ce qu'il y a
pas un bilan négatif à faire quand même
de cette séparation des activités et un
enjeu à revenir à un EDF intégré avec la
production le transport la distribution
et deuxième question
pour le coup ça se passe en 2004 ou EDF
et GDF passe perdre leur statut d'épic
et deviennent des sociétés anonymes
alors sur EDF d'une certaine façon la
question précédente va vous permettre
d'y répondre mais sur GDF qu'on vient
d'évoquer quel bilan on peut faire aussi
de cette privatisation on a posé la
question hier au représentant syndicaux
dont un avec fait sa carrière
précédemment chez GDF il était très
critique de cette privatisation quel
bilan vous vous pouvez en faire
j'essaie vraiment de réfléchir parce que
c'est pas non mais
sur le premier point
allusion tout à l'heure
EDF
reste l'opérateur le plus intégré
d'Europe
[Musique]
la séparation
est née GDF je constate simplement que
pardon RTE et nenich
qu'apparemment la gouvernance cette
bonne qualité
que ça répond aux attentes que le
dialogue notamment d'enedis avec les
collectivités locales les syndicats
locaux d'électricité se passe bien enfin
j'ai plutôt l'impression que ça marche
bon alors est-ce que on peut faire 30
ans avant
je sais pas vous dire mais
moi j'ai plutôt le sentiment alors moi
je veux dire les trucs qui marchent si
on est touché pas trop c'est pas mal
quoi
je pense que il y a des moments où il y
a souvent enfin il est assez rare qu'ils
ont prennent vraiment la mauvaise
décision et ce qui est sûr c'est que les
circonstances changent et que si vous
adaptez pas une ancienne très bonne
décision peut devenir une catastrophe
exemple le pilotage
ça et en matière d'énergie c'est sûr ça
c'est une certitude
maintenant
bon voilà la République française a fait
des choix
avec des gouvernants successifs ont tous
voilà qui sont tous salés dans dans une
voilà une construction européenne dans
laquelle il y avait l'énergie
faire de d'un petit fiction que
d'essayer d'imaginer ce que ça aurait
été si ça avait été autrement parce que
honnêtement je ne sais pas je sais pas
et la même chose pour aider à
franchement je sais pas moi je suis
quand même assez convaincu que c'est un
sujet politique l'énergie voilà
comme disait Lénine
communiste les soviettes plus
électricité bon je conseille à que c'est
un sujet absolument majeur je considère
qu'il est petit que le marché vienne
appuyer à certains moments pour capter
des investissements ne me choque pas au
contraire il faut probablement l'idée
mais c'est un sujet de stratégie
collective
j'ai passé trois années de ma vie à
monter une agence d'électrification en
Afrique parce que 650 millions
d'Africains n'ont pas accès à l'énergie
mes enfants on est dingue c'est à 14 km
de chez nous c'est notre lieu de
croissance et d'expansion de croissance
y compris de PIB par par la proximité
où ça va être notre âme vous savez
je pense que l'Europe aurait bien raison
de de de
proposer à la disposition en Afrique un
énorme plan d'énergie renouvelable pour
toute l'Afrique alors il se débrouille
pour l'instant au Maroc très bien on
pourrait peut-être y participer mais
c'est un sujet majeur donc penser que
les seules lois le marché doit venir en
appui
de quelque chose de régalien pour moi
c'est régalien
merci Monsieur Miss j'ai passé la parole
maintenant à Francis Dubois
merci Monsieur le Ministre déjà pour vos
réponses c'est la façon d'imager les
choses qui nous permettent de de très
bien comprendre donc vous avez parlé au
début de ce qui s'est passé au niveau du
Grenelle de l'environnement où on a bien
compris que chacun les ONG le
gouvernement était bien à sa place et
dans une discussion qui permettait de
porter et donc un projet environnemental
et notamment en matière également de
souveraineté énergétique et de
résilience
à cette question on a bien vu qu'à ce
moment là les choses sont claires et
bien définies avec vous l'avez dit les
ONG ne sont pas opposées donc au
nucléaire
qu'est-ce que vous pensez aujourd'hui de
de l'influence politique des ONG ou il y
en a-t-il où il y en a t-il eu au sein
des cabinets ministériels c'est ma
première question ensuite vous nous avez
parlé au niveau de vous avez bien imagé
sur le un pilote dans une voiture il
était important d'avoir une piste un
pilote au sein d'une voiture et je suis
tout à fait en accord avec vous et sur
on l'a bien compris que si on veut
retrouver notre souveraineté et notre
résilience il faut être on est sur des
stratégies de temps long
quel que soit d'ailleurs le mix
on est vous êtes revenu là-dessus et
on a reçu donc le directeur de cabinet
du premier ministre Édouard Philippe qui
nous dit qui était directeur de cabinet
de 2017 à 2020 monsieur ribado Dumas et
qui nous dit que à un moment donné ils
font le choix
[Musique]
de fermer ainsi que donc nucléaire parce
que ça coûtait trop cher
est-ce que pour vous ces choix-là et
dans un dans des stratégies de temps
long et
ça nous amène à comment définir ce
pilote j'ai cru comprendre que vous
souhaitez un ministère de l'Énergie fort
est-ce que c'est
ces choix il se doivent si on veut
garder notre souveraineté se doivent
être comptable ou plutôt être plus sur
des choix industriels et quel qu'en soit
le coup si on veut revenir donc à un
prix de l'énergie et une
souveraineté donc énergétique ensuite
vous êtes vous avez parlé également
qu'il était important d'avoir un pilote
aussi que cette arène soit pilotée
on a vous l'avez dit dans cet accès
régulier de l'énergie il y avait un
engagement de 100 térawatts sous
condition de tarif donc piloté et
réévaluer
on sait que depuis 2014 le président
Philippe de Ladoucette nous a bien
confirmé que il y avait un décret qui
devait sortir en 2014 sur donc la
réévaluation de la reine et dans ces
moments là est-ce que vous pourriez nous
répondre sur le phénomène que à partir
du moment où il y a une révaluation mais
il y a 100 terawatts en face est-ce
qu'il aurait pas été possible et
notamment avec tous les problèmes de
maintenance et de corrosion sous
contrainte de baisser aussi c'est
sans térawattheure qui correspondait à
ce moment-là
un pourcentage moindre par rapport à la
production du nucléaire actuel et je et
ma dernière question serait sur vous dit
un moment sur le marché régulièrement
européen
on aurait dû s'y suspendre des mars 2022
est-ce que vous pourriez nous nous
expliquer comment on aurait pu suspendre
des mars 2022
je vous remercie de vous répondre
merci
je vous la poste tout de suite en 2009 à
la radio chez Europe 1 vous dites donc
et j'ouvre les guillemets c'est vous qui
parlez monsieur le ministre et je pense
que vous avez pas bégayé quand vous avez
dit ces propos la Révolution française
la révolution énergétique française
c'est économie d'énergie économie
d'énergie économie d'énergie
avec un développement très puissant des
ENR
pour ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
ce que vous vouliez dire ce jour-là
alors dans l'ordre
poser la question des ONG
ler
oui non d'abord je voudrais revenir sur
sur un point
les ONG ont pas dit ok au nucléaire
faites pas dire ce que je n'ai pas dit
ce que j'ai dit c'est que le fait qu'on
est cette stratégie nucléaire arrêtée
qui s'arrête à deux EPR pas après et
le reste n'était pas casus Belly
suffisant pour qu'il me considère pas
qu'on pouvait faire tout le Grenelle
ensemble
c'est alors que sur l'extraction minière
de la mine d'or en Guyane
c'était un casus belli il y aurait pas
eu grandir c'est donc je veux pas les
mettre en porte-à-faux et leur faire
dire ce qu'ils n'ont pas dit mais
c'était une donnée de base qui est
accepte qui a été tolérée voilà tout
simplement alors les les ONG moi
j'arrive pas
ça c'est comme les lobbystes
ils viennent vous voir c'est bien de
d'écouter tout le monde
je n'ai pas souvenu et puis et puis j'ai
parfois été mis en minorité enfin
minorité mais mais en désaccord j'ai dit
quand on fait la rénovation urbaine
500600000 logements 200.000 démolition
et avec des gens qui a juste au-dessus
disaient mais on a déjà une crise du
logement
c'est-à-dire je peux comprendre qu'il y
ait des opinions elles peuvent être
entendues
mais il s'appelle pas ça moi du lobby ou
de la force des ONG il y a des ONG qui
ont des compétences parlons
exceptionnelles
exceptionnel prenez Robin des Bois fans
il y a des travaux scientifiques c'est
pas c'est pas vous faites le tri vous
n'êtes pas obligé de mais écouter
je pense que l'action publique c'est
d'abord d'abord écouter aller au fond
des choses au fond est-ce qu'on vous
présente comme des évidences genre la
reine est un problème d'asymétrie qui
explique les Violets de la Norvège ça va
une blague ça
commode non c'est écouter moi maintenant
vous dire que j'ai subi des pressions
oui des vrais comment on peut dire
de toute ma créativité que jamais
jamais voilà donc moi je n'ai pas
souvenir alors mais en plus comme quand
vous avez passé quelques milliers
d'heures
pas besoin de vous revoir tous les 15
jours donc on a une feuille de route le
drame de la France je veux dire on
décide 256 mesures Grenelle en effet
voter
mais le sujet pardon on a fait le suivi
le comité de suivi pendant un an
et après
il est dans la loi le comité de suivi
il a jamais eu elles sont où les 256
mesures votées par le Parlement on en
est où il y en a peut-être des idiotes
qu'il faut rectifier il y en a peut-être
accéléré il y en a peut-être qui sont
partis au contraire mais évidemment
notre drame c'est le suivi pilotage et
suivi ça sert à rien de voter c'est
comme la rénovation urbaine le Parlement
vote
un énorme parc à détruire à construire à
résidence puis tout d'un coup le truc
qui s'arrête mais quand je dis ça il
s'arrête
allez comme passer 40
milliards là ou 48 financés en fait par
les opérateurs eux-mêmes pardon de le
dire tu n'es pas par l'État bon pour
l'essentiel papa état et bien donc
personne n'est décidé qu'il est le moins
de débat le truc il s'est juste arrêté
parce que plus personne n'a suivi le
truc voilà tout simplement
l'énergie va l'étendre c'est de la du
pilotage et du suivi voilà
256 mesures et bien monsieur le
Président
qui dépasse ma condition d'aujourd'hui
mais
pourquoi est-ce que il répondait masse
ou est-ce qu'on arrive de 256 pour voir
ce qui était une bêtise d'ailleurs des
trucs à modifier des trucs accélérer
le mot Grenelle qui était devenu un mot
juridique parce que il y avait des
certificats il y avait vous savez qu'on
a dépensé de l'argent pour le supprimer
de la Documentation française
ça c'est la réalité
donc nos sujets nécessitent un consensus
et de la continuité voilà
ça peut pas être c'est pas possible
alors vous m'avez posé une autre
question
[Musique]
oui
la reine est une est un système qui
devait on avait plus loin des tarifs
réglementés on avait plus droit au mois
de juillet de la réversibilité on avait
des conséquences civiles et commerciaux
on a des comptions européens et on nous
disait les alternatives ils peuvent pas
investir parce que il y a pas de
visibilité parce que au milieu
c'est ça la situation on met en place un
outil alors après avoir compté le couple
Parlement il y a eu vous allez voir les
échanges extraordinaires avec
le noir avec François Brotte avec c'est
pas un truc c'était ça a été lourd ça a
été long il y a une maquette qui est
posée qu'on doit piloter en permanence
on aurait pu passer à 60 et on aurait pu
passer à 58 et puis repasser oui bien
sûr mais c'est le pilotage ça toutes les
conditions évoluent voilà c'est pour ça
que la loi elfique pas un prix elle fixe
une modalité de fixation voilà et c'est
pas la creux qui fiche le prix la creux
donne un avis et c'est nécessaire
mais à quoi elle est pas parfaite non
plus de la nation voilà qui a abandonné
faire présenter par des gens qui
provisorment mais c'est comme ça
oui alors ce que j'avais dit sur cette
bonne radio de repas
oui oui je maintiens je maintiens mais
je maintiens mes
moi je vous dis qu'on peut faire des
appels d'offres aujourd'hui vous verrez
vous aurez des réponses sur les
bâtiments à 80 % 90% des missions de CO2
en moi 75% de factures énergétiques en
moi lançons les appels d'offres
Carrefour la fait Airbus l'a fait pour
l'instant c'est le privé
mais on dirait à des coûts qui sont très
très inférieurs
au thermique pur je dis pas qu'il faut
pas faire du thermique mais il y a une
révolution oui il faut qu'on est fondre
c'est à dire la consommation doit
devenir intelligente par des outils
d'intelligence artificielle
digitalisation voilà ça ma conviction
absolue et je vous dis c'est notre seul
solution parce que le gap avant que les
autres la démarrent
on aura 40% de besoin en plus
vous avez vu que aux États-Unis aux
États-Unis en
Floride Floride aux Californie je me
souviens plus pour pas changer votre
voiture électrique passer 18 heures
oui oui
mais la souris c'est pas de baisser de
deux de degrés c'est pas c'est bien mais
mais ça c'est la vraie révolution elle
est devant nous on est au tout début on
est au premier semestre quasiment de
cette nouvelle ère
prendre des mars 2022 vous m'avez pas
répondu comment on fait les Portugais
les Espagnols je sais pas comment ils
ont organisé je sais pas comment il
faudrait l'organiser ici mais on n'est
pas obligé de suivre nous de capter
notre prix de l'électricité sur le prix
du marché de gros européen ils sont on
décide à qui provisoire parce qu'il
s'agit pas de tout foutre-mer bien
entendu fait trois quatre mois et puis
aujourd'hui c'est quasi on doit pas être
très très loin des des prix initiaux moi
je suis pas suivi dans le détail mais ce
que je veux dire c'est que voilà on peut
être pro européen on peut trouver qu'il
faut des attaques on peut même être pour
un voilà que le marché Vienne en support
mais on doit garder toujours le pilotage
et c'est pas la mécanique a été mise en
place qui doit piloter le truc voilà
quand il y a des crises
quand il y a des évolutions quand il y a
des adaptations nécessaires ou quand il
y a des nouvelles technologies
on est d'accord de dire que c'est une
volonté de gouvernementale
et je dirais que sur un sujet comme
celui-là je dirais vraiment de la nation
parce que vous avez beaucoup
d'intervenants bon le gouvernement il a
il a il a une responsabilité il a pas
toutes les responsabilités d'ailleurs
vous avez des autorités indépendantes
que la crue est une autorité
indépendante autorité sur tes nucléaire
est une autoritaire indépendante les
investisseurs sont indépendants les
voyez les syndicats c'est vraiment c'est
une famille complète donc
un gouvernement doit créer un consensus
de la famille le plus proche possible
merci Monsieur ministre je crois qu'il
revient de conclure d'abord les échanges
étaient passionnants merci d'être venu
jusqu'à nous pour témoigner de votre
expérience qui est grande moi en guise
de conclusion je voudrais si vous
pouviez de manière synthétique nous dire
si
cette période que vous êtes vous allez
traverser de l'instant où vous étiez au
responsabilité jusqu'à maintenant parce
que vous êtes quand même un acteur
éclairé du sujet qu'est-ce qu'il a
manqué pour
on a bien entendu le pilotage la volonté
politique etc mais à votre sens est-ce
qu'il y a des regrets est-ce que vous
avez des regrets soient personnels soit
des regrets de choses qui n'ont pas été
faites sans forcément mettre en
accusation des gens sur notamment les
compétences en matière de nucléaire
parce qu'on n'a pas tout abordé enfin je
sais que le thorium ne peut pas être un
sujet par exemple pour la France parce
que c'est pas intéressant mais on aurait
pu évoquer ça est-ce qu'on a pas
suffisamment investi dans la fusion
alors qu'on voit qu'aujourd'hui aux
États-Unis dernièrement il y a quand
même eu des résultats qui sont assez
extraordinaires et on a peut-être laissé
partir nos compétences pourquoi vous
l'avez dit ça a été plus culturel
qu'autre chose mais on aurait peut-être
pu combattre ce côté culturel français
qui fait que les énergies renouvelables
se sont pas développées à la hauteur de
vos espoirs et des deux Grenelles que
vous avez fait donc ça retraçait un
petit peu si vous si vous voyez des
regrets ou des choses qu'on aurait pu
être mise en place et puis la question
de la fin en tout cas pour moi c'est que
on parle de souveraineté énergétique
française
simplement une utopie et pour vous poser
cette question là j'en fais référence et
j'en suis d'accord avec vous avec le
potentiel énergétique extraordinaire de
l'Afrique qui sera sûrement beaucoup
plus forte que tous les pays du monde
donc je voulais vous poser la question
en guise de conclusion sur votre
intervention aujourd'hui
sentiment de cette période d'abord c'est
que
personne ne nous a entravé
je parle de l'équipe on était une équipe
personne
les choix qui ont été faits ils ont été
pesés on peut les discuter mais
c'est notre faute si des choses ont pas
fonctionné
très derrière personne
Bercy à cette époque là ne nous posait
aucune difficulté d'aucune sorte vous
pouvez avoir des visions mais c'était
juste normal mais on pilotait on était
en charge voilà et on avait la confiance
du Parlement mais quand je dis du
Parlement je dirais pas de la majorité
de présidentiel de l'époque et la
Grenelle a été votée à la quasi
unanimité
sentiment qu'on pouvait vraiment faire
des trucs
et qu'on les aide et qu'on les a fait
après un énorme regret c'est de
c'est de pas avoir je sais pas trouver
la façon pour m'assurer que les comités
de suivi
qui se réunissaient tous les mois ou
tous les trimestres je me souviens plus
parce que parce que tout le temps
c'était tout le temps ça durait 4 heures
ce soit arrêté alors
je pense qu'on les avait prévues dans la
loi non seulement il y avait non son
accueil il y avait même des copils et
puis il y avait des plans Plan Bâtiment
Philippe Pelletier plan transport plan
qui ont continué à perdurer mais dans
l'indifférence générale
ouais de pas avoir été foutu de trouver
une martingale qui oblige à ce qu'on
suive
en modifiant qu'on suive ce qui avait
été décidé par la nation tout entière
voilà ça c'est j'ai pas trouvé cette
martingale là
c'est mon plus grand regret au fond
alors après je pensais qu'on a
après c'est des choix c'est des choix
assez contradictoires parfois mais
non c'est pas d'énormes
prenez le suivi pardon d'être obsédé par
ça parce que mais je pense que c'est la
clé de l'action publique
je vous ai dit ce que je croyais j'avais
entendu dans des débats ici que c'était
le lobby de DS tout ça c'est des blagues
évidemment que non c'est un vrai cœur
mais en même temps toujours pareil il y
a pas de pilote
quand
vous suspendez les tarifs de rachat
après quand vous les remettez en cause
il y a bien eu pas si longtemps que ça
des tarifs de rachat garantis par l'état
français
qui sont remis en cause
en cours de contrat
donc il y a des instabilités qui sont
pernicieuses je pense à celui là mais
mais sur les renouvelables oui je pense
que c'est ça manquait de oui de
il y a des difficultés dans des
programmes que cela bien sûr
en résumé monsieur le Président
c'est un sujet extraordinaire
quand moi votre commission qui va
probablement au-delà de l'intitulé même
me semble-t-il permettez-moi de
citoyens de vous le dire moi je suis
impressionné par
impressionné par les ce que j'ai entendu
pas de moi des autres
attention facilité
attention
la bonne explication est rarement celle
qui est la plus facile à expliquer
[Musique]
il y a une société qui bouge
voilà je vous remercie en tous les cas
de m'avoir écouté
merci beaucoup monsieur Dinis cet
après-midi enfin cet après-midi cette
fin de service après midi était
passionnante il est important vraiment
pour la commission d'enquête de prendre
connaissance non seulement des mesures
qui ont été prises il y a déjà une
quinzaine d'années des problématiques
d'alors mais de votre vision
de ce qu'on devrait ou pourrait faire
aujourd'hui pour essayer d'atteindre non
pas on l'a bien compris la souveraineté
énergétique mais en tout cas pour avoir
une énergie
plus facile plus pilotable et si je peux
me permettre l'introduction de
l'intelligence artificielle est une
évidence absolue c'est le pilotage
effectivement de l'énergie qui nous
permettra demain d'y arriver et merci
pour votre venue et je rappelle aux
membres de la commission simplement que
la commission d'enquête se réunira la
semaine prochaine merci à tous et à
toutes et à la semaine prochaine